benji it took him eight hours 22 minutes
and 55 seconds to complete the marathon
i think in his age group benji finished
ahead of two people and out of the whole
marathon benji finished 24 857 out of
nine thousand nine hundred forty they
claim that by the time benji finished
the marathon the winner of the marathon
was back in kenya enjoying the dinner
well one of our guys went out to support
him and it's typical of benji he said
you know what like i wouldn't even call
it a marathon he was strolling he says
and like not really putting much effort
he was just you know just walking it
wasn't any effort at all put into it he
ate an entire frozen pizza right before
the marathon
and the night before for dinner he had 2
000 calorie dinner you know the morning
he ate a pizza yeah yeah and then like
he's so worried about maintaining his
calorie intake that he ran with so many
clif bars in his pocket for snacks that
it weighed down his pants they kept
falling they kept falling out of his
pants cliff bars to walk that's where
people were running
they're like trying to keep energy going
through there okay you're worried about
it bring one cliff bar he had so many
they along the route they were falling
out of his pockets and he's walking it's
not like i'm going to hope that he
brought those for others who might have
forgotten to bring something so i ran a
marathon yesterday and this morning i'm
checking all the photos everybody i
follow so i checked benji
he literally is posing in the park
before the race with a pizza and then
he has on a hat with a towel long sleeve
t-shirt short sleeve t-shirt cargo
shorts
sweatpants and two sweatshirts tied
around his legs god
yeah
cargo shorts we can go on a safari man
why would you wear cargo shorts benji
like at least get a pair of like nice
walking shorts or running shorts
so i could uh hold everything that was
that was character but why do you need
quite serious i mean i don't know if
it's stick or what are you doing it for
laughs because i can't figure you out
like oh no the cargo shorts i mean i i
was really trying like why so many cliff
bars dude i mean you're walking you
could certainly survive for eight hours
with one cliff
i was like oh what if i get way too
hungry then i can't then i just don't
have you know
and that hunger keeps me from finishing
it 83 people were behind you that's it
well first of all i started at the very
back well they start people at different
stages
because there's so many runners you
should have started on saturday and the
marathon was on sunday
maybe the clif bars weighed you down i
mean that's well
yeah i i sure had too many cliff bars i
mean i remember watching the marathon
and there'd be people like who were like
you know around dinner time already they
weren't in and and there'd be like cabs
like taxi cabs stuck behind people
that's benji there's a guy
he's holding up traffic it was scary
towards the end because
it was dark it's over and the course
yeah and uh like i almost got i was with
a group of people we almost got lost up
in the bronx are those the same clothes
you wore the marathon
this is my shirt and my bib he's wearing
the same [ __ ] clothes he wore the
marathon
in my medal right all right benji
congratulations on your marathon and uh
and and and
and your medal very nice thank you
my uh i
took it to show uh my grocery store
people last night and they they they
made a bigger deal out of it than you
did
yep well they didn't see i mean they
were really happy for me yeah well they
think you ran and they didn't know you
were in cargo shorts with
so many cliff bars that they started
falling out of your pockets